MIN-MIN LIANG: So my philosophy
of teaching Chinese-- well
it's a very interesting
process because when I started,
I knew one method.
And I thought that was
the best in the world,
to do drill instruct-- drill
the students all the time,
make them repeat.
But throughout the
years, I realized
they can say certain
things, but they could not
have a conversation.
So they can do well on tests.
It doesn't mean they can
go and have a conversation.
So I think I've
evolved, and right now I
think the main
philosophy for me is
to have a welcoming
environment to help students
to speak the language, not
to talk about the language.
So that's my current
philosophical idea.
So everything I do
is to carry this
out and create an environment
for this philosophy.
So I did a lot right
for the past few years.
I started changing,
and I did a lot--
they said scaffolding
instructions and very
student-centered instruction.
I used to be very
teacher-centered.
Which is very efficient.
Don't get me wrong.
It's a very effective tool.
You kept the students
on their toes.
They have to
[INAUDIBLE] right away.
And I got this
evaluation one year.
And they said, oh, the
teacher is incredible.
She was so good, but I wish
I can learn how to speak.
I was like, what does that mean?
And you spoke well.
And I realized he was
doing the drill pattern.
He can say a certain
sentence when I asked
him to say and repeat after me.
But have him to have
a natural conversation
was really difficult.
So that dawned on me.
I start changing.
And I try to attend
conference and workshop,
not related to just
teaching Chinese.
More like how to educate people.
More education and how to create
an environment for all students
to feel safe.
So I adapt those philosophies
in my course, too.
So my philosophy is a
welcoming environment.
That means building a
community for students
to feel very safe to speak the
language in this community.
They're not afraid
to make mistakes.
And they'll always
volunteer their opinions.
That's my goal.
The first step.
As I said, my philosophy is to
create a welcoming environment,
to build a community.
So for example, recently--
two years ago-- I
went to a workshop called
Responsive Classroom.
Responsive Classroom is
geared to K through 12.
It's more treating the
younger kids-- try to get rid
of the behavior issue.
I don't need to do
that in my classroom.
But I think the strategy
of theirs actually works.
First thing they do
is building community.
So for example, I do the
first week of my course--
and these are hard to learn.
They already know how to speak.
But they are so
embarrassed with them
because they would tell
me, my pronunciation bad.
I don't speak to anybody
else, only to my parents.
I don't want to speak
in the classroom.
So basically, I do the greeting.
The very easy things
they're comfortable with.
For instance, they talk about
their name, what their major,
they can all speak
these in Chinese.
So what I do is the
first day like that.
And then start it-- I
build into a routine.
So every class I spend five
to 10 minutes every day--
we call greet-- every
class, not every day.
We don't have a everyday
class-- called greeting.
Basically I ask everybody to
write their name on the card.
So I collect the card.
I put the card in the
middle of the classroom.
I would start because I
need to model what it means.
So I will pick up
a student's card.
For instance, I
say, oh, Sarah Ling.
OK and I call her
in her Chinese name.
And I would start saying,
how are you today?
What did you do last night?
Stuff like that.
Daily life things.
And then I ask a student,
did you see what I did?
So follow my model, and
come here, pick up a card,
greet your classmates.
So every day I would do this.
I think after two
weeks, everybody
knows everybody's name.
And while greeting
this is not just simple
greeting because you have
a natural conversation when
you say oh, I went to bed
really late last night.
And people would say, why?
So I started very
structured, for instance,
just everybody just say
very limited things.
And then I would
say, OK, so Sarah
says she went to bed
really late last night.
Do you guys want to know why?
All in Chinese, so they
would start asking.
So I build on that difficulty.
The Monday class is really fun.
They love it because you
can talk about weekend.
So kids here, they did all kinds
of activity during the weekend.
So they're so interested
in finding out
what their classmate did because
they might not know each other.
Some took classes together.
So they would [INAUDIBLE]
same course together
in the classroom.
Many teachers probably
think it's a waste of time.
Why are you talking about that?
But I think through this,
you build a community.
So the moment they walk into
the classroom, after one month,
they could have a test
before the top Chinese class.
The moment they walk into--
because of these greeting
rituals, they have to switch
their gear into speaking
Chinese right away.
And because you're
having a conversation,
so you really need to
engage your classmates.
So that's what I mean
building a community.
They feel so freely.
Can talk about
anything they could.
And they don't know the
words, they will ask me,
how do you say this?
This is what I'm
doing right now.
It's really blah, blah, blah.
And people really
want to find out.
And I add another
component after a few weeks
is to-- by the time now, they
already know each other's name.
Every lesson, I ask
them to write an essay.
I give them a topic
to write an essay.
So I will ask them,
for instance, I'll say,
we talk about family.
So our topic is Chinese family.
So I wanted them
to go home to write
about maybe Italian
family or Spanish family.
So the structure.
Model on the textbook.
So nobody knows what other
students are writing about.
So this time we call sharing.
So this sharing part is to
talk about what did you write.
So some students, oh, I
wrote about Spanish family.
And I said, what was that?
Tell us not just the title.
What was the content about?
So they talk about--
everybody has a chance
to talk about quickly.
And then I said, oh,
this is very interesting.
So student will automatically,
naturally, just ask,
why did you pick this topic?
Did you know any Spanish people?
So the natural
conversation just flows.
So they get into a routine.
So every time they
come to my classroom,
they know they
should speak Chinese.
And they should talk
about their life.
And that's what they're good at.
They cannot talk about politics.
They cannot talk about history.
But they can talk
about themselves.
And so to make the oral
proficiency higher,
and they can speak much better.
I remember there's one student
after the Thanksgiving--
she came back.
She was so excited.
She said oh, [INAUDIBLE]
that's how they address me
as teacher-- and said, you know,
I my father had this friend.
And I always call him Uncle.
He is from China.
He doesn't speak any English.
So I met him in New York
when it was September.
I cannot communicate
with him at all.
So during the
Thanksgiving, my home
is so far away, so I
went to my uncle's place.
And I can talk to him.
And he kept saying that
my Chinese improved.
And she said, oh my god,
it's only two months.
I can't believe I can
speak the most Chinese.
Even though I speak
Chinese with my parents,
I can never speak to anybody.
And she just came
back so excited.
And I feel great.
So I know it worked.
Because to her it's
talking, speaking in Chinese
doesn't have to be something she
has to think about-- how do I
come up with the
first sentence--
anymore because she does
that in our class every time.
So it's very natural for her.
And plus, she
actually knows Chinese
because of her background.
So she crossed the barrier
to be able to speak
to other people,
which is fantastic.